-Hi, Regina. How are ya?
-I'm...good.
I was gonna say great,
but I was like
that didn't feel 100% true
But I'm good.
How are you?
-I should say I'm as great as
can be, to be talking to you
Let's put it like that.
-Thanks.
That's nice.
-So, this is --
you are, at this moment,
sort of a historical
footnote on the show.
You were supposed to be on
the night that --
it was a Thursday in March -
we decided at around 2:00
in the afternoon
to call things --
the whole thing off.
But you were coming
into the studio.
-I was dressed.
I had picked out the most
beautiful dress for you.
-[ Laughs ]
-Very excited to wear it.
But, yes, yeah,
it did, it shut down.
I came home.
I was in New York, working
and I came home right before
I think you guys shut down
right before it got
-Yes.
-crazy.
-The crazy thing, as well,
is that you were coming on
to promote "Black Monday,"
which is about the
stock market crash,
and then, that day was
the biggest stock market dro
since black Monday,
which was, I mean,
very unfortunate, but also
accurate tie-in to your show
-Yeah. We were, you know,
kind of excited,
you know, in a twisted way
We were like,
"Oh, look, this could be -
This is so sad,
but this could be great."
Because it was really odd
to have history
repeating itself in that way
-And also, to credit the show,
it's not just
about the stock market.
It is a very dark comedy
that talks about things
like race as well, so even
though it takes place in 1987,
you have made
a very timely show.
-I know.
You know, it's scary
'cause you ask yourself, "Wow,
so, you see a lotta areas
where things really
still need to progress,
where there's like
progression opportunity.
And, you know, it's fun for us
because we are poking fun
at a lotta things historically
but also, the fact that it's
timely also adds to it.
So, yeah, it's been --
It's a fun show to shoot.
I do have to say that.
-I mean, talking about wor
that feels very current
and of the moment,
you also did a film,
a couple of years ago,
called "The Hate U Give."
This is a movie that is
incredibly well-reviewed
and, because it is
about a police officer shooting,
it does seem like a movie
that a lot of people
are discovering now.
Have you found that to be
the case as well?
-I do.
I mean, I think, you know,
everything that's going on
in the world, you know,
and not just
in the United States,
but in the world globally,
I think,
the fact that people
have had to put their normal
activities on pause
has really given them
the room to take notice
of things
that have been going on.
And so, I think,
when we came out, you know
there were a lotta movies
and a lotta things
and people were busy
and going to work
and maybe like, "Oh, I don't -
I wanna watch something
happy," you know?
And I think, now, people
are really in the process
of wanting change and evolution.
And so, now,
they're discovering it
and it's resonating with the
in a completely different wa
than I think it did
two years ago,
when they just didn't see it
-It's really special
to make a work with integrit
because that,
of course, ages well
and then, when people need
something to go to,
to help them work
through these moments,
it's nice that
it's there for them.
-Yeah. And I think a lot
of people thought
the film was gonna be hopeless
but it's actually,
it's also a very,
in it's own weird way,
it's a coming-of-age story
And so I think our youth,
which, you know,
and they're doing so much
in the world right now.
I mean, you're watching them
kinda galvanize
and I think,
for them to see the movie,
it's a very empowering movie
It's what we all can do,
but it's this young girl
and her group of friends,
how they band together
and what they do,
along with everyone else,
so I think it touches
a lotta things that are
going on today.